[Music]
let's go to
not andrea andrea it's andre it's that
right andrea from san angelo texas
andrea how do i see it am i saying it
right
you're saying it right you got it andrea
yes sir
beautiful beautiful is that a family
name
um no actually it's not
dude good for your folks that's
fantastic all right so what's up oh
well after a bit of a hiatus i found
myself dating again this year
met a great guy really big in the family
but one of his family relationships has
me feeling a little bit uncomfortable
and honestly a bit jealous at times
and i'm wondering if i'm just
overreacting and overthinking the
situation or if there could legitimately
be some relationship red flags i need to
think about okay tell me more this is
you've peaked my interest this is
fascinating
well um so
uh we've been dating for a couple months
now the entire time i've known him due
to life situations he's been living with
a particular family member and so he
lives with her and they work together
who is it mom or sister who is it
no i i i'm not gonna disclose that okay
okay um yeah i'd rather not put that out
there right now okay um it's not it's
not mom okay all right it's a younger
family member and um so there
so he lives with her and um works with
her they have similar lifestyles so they
spend all their time together they run
errands together and in general just
kind of do life together all the time um
and then
it's
it makes it a little strange because at
times and i'll call them and i'll say
hey what are you doing i get a lot of
the wee answers well
we are here we are there we are doing
this and i'll say hey do you want to go
do something and he'll be like well let
me find out what we're doing tonight
and
he won't make you know he won't make
plans with me unless he's cleared it
with her first like he'll check in with
her and see what she's doing and i guess
make sure he's not missing out on
something i don't know but he'll clear
it with her first and
on a couple occasions when i've actually
planned for us to do things together
he's invited her along okay how how
how old is he
uh we're in our 40s how how old is the
she
uh she's also in her 40s okay she's a
little she's younger than he is
okay all right so my first thought was
he's 25 and she's 16 and he's just
trying to help out okay
so they're both 40s okay um
i mean so
i hesitate it sounds weird but i
hesitate to say it i hesitate to say
it's wrong and
i i am particularly attuned
to
romantic partners who are jealous of
their siblings um relationships i don't
think that's fair and i use i usually
think that's pretty annoying um but
my any let me let me say it this way
anytime i get a question like this my
first question is always back to
the one person that can
that i can communicate with which is you
and
have you sat down and had this
conversation with him
i have yes how did that come how did you
enter into that conversation and how did
it go
um well i just approached and said um
babe you know i i know our family life
are different but
this is how this particular relationship
is making me feel right now and i was
told not to be jealous of his
relationship with this person and not to
come between him and his family
okay and that was pretty much the end of
conversation so here here is a a hard
but beautiful truth you got
a boundary
a very very clear one
and the choice you have now is do i want
to live in this situation that makes me
feel uncomfortable for whatever reason
if if he always if he required celery at
every meal
and he chewed it with his mouth open so
loud
and you said hey i
i love you
would you call hey babe uh i love you
um
but the salary
it's got it's got like can we do gum and
he's like
celery stays don't get between me and my
vegetables
then you would know i have a choice to
make
can i fall deeper and madly in love
with
or can i not and some could and some
couldn't and so you've got a very clear
this is my relationship with
my family member this is how it's gonna
be
and you will always be
an adjunct to that
relationship so you're getting an answer
whether you like that answer or not or
that answer is brutal and hard i get
uh but yeah it sounds like you're in a
fortunate place often people don't get
answers and you sounds like you got one
so
you got that how'd that answer make you
feel
um
not very good honestly right um i makes
me feel like a kind of a third wheel
kind of like a an additive to his life
and not a primary focus
yes i think i mean sounds that sounds
right
what i what i'm worried about you is
trying to
work your way into
becoming the primary focus
and i don't know if it's a relationship
this is just a
situational relationship because i know
he came across some hard times a while
back and then didn't really have any
place to go so i ended up moving with
family
and so i guess as a part of me is
somewhat hopeful that maybe this is just
situational
and that if things change that this
relationship
dynamic could as well
but i don't know so when you talk to him
about it did he say
i know this is a little bit odd um
that i bring my
basically the same age um sibling or
whoever it is along with us cousin
whoever it is on dates together
and that i have to run by all of my
social activities and romantic
activities by
this other woman who i'm related to that
i live with
i know that sounds weird this is a weird
moment in my life and i'm working
towards did you get that or did you get
this is the way this is and don't get
between it
oh
kind of a little bit i say a little bit
of both because i've got the whole you
know this is the way it is don't get
between it
but i've also gotten the
you know hey this is just the way it is
right now
so i'm i'm getting some mixed messages
and i'm just gonna can i tell you i
don't think you are i don't think you
are
i think you really really want to take
the message you're getting and make it
like
turn it a certain way so you can absorb
it as just right now because i think
he's a great guy and i think you've been
alone for a while is that fair
yeah
and so
i don't know what your past dating
history looks like um and it sounds like
it's taking you a while to get back in
the game
you're worth more than what you got
right now
and if he was on the phone with me
here's what i would tell him
he is welcome to this relationship with
this other person
but it's unfair it's dishonorable to
drag another human being along as a toy
on this ride
if you're gonna date somebody and start
thinking about creating a new world with
them they become priority over your
relationship with your
your live-in relationship with your
sibling
you know what i mean
yeah i do
and
just for everybody listening who just
went what
also
if my
wife and her brother wanted to go on a
like a brother-sister trip a couple of
times a year i would celebrate that
i want them to have the greatest
relationship in the world
my sister and i do stuff together like
there should never be a weird thing
unless i make it weird you know what i
mean
yeah yeah totally i love his family i
mean they're they're great people and i
love the fact he's very much into them i
think
i think you like the idea of being a
part of this beautiful system
the one problem is you're not a part of
it you're outside of it
yeah you are not being asked into it you
are being told this is where you will be
and i i hate that for you
but that appears to be the reality
um
here if i'm you here's my next step
here's my next step it's a very direct
um i've thought about this and i'm not
interested in
a
furthering this relationship
if
another woman be it your mom your sister
your cousin
is going to be more important to you
than me
you're welcome to that but if that's the
case cut me loose or if that's the case
i'm going to head out and it's been an
honor getting to know you and to date
you
but i'm not going to play second fiddle
in this relationship
and if he says no i'm ready to make you
first fiddle
and once a week him and his sister
first fiddle if he says that you
probably should run just run for the
hills you're gonna be my first fiddle
yeah actually i'm out i'm out that's
weird
um
but if he does say no no i'm ready to
make you first in my life
and i've been through some hard stuff
and i'm ready to shift
um
but me and my me and my sister my cousin
my mom whoever get together once a week
for a dinner or for breakfast or
whatever
celebrate that
celebrate that
help them grow in their relationship
but unfortunately doesn't sound like
where you're at
so it's like you've been given a very
clear boundary and you want it to be
something different and i want it for
you but it's not reality
one of the keys to being well is owning
and acknowledging reality
and you're worth more than what you got
right now
i hope you can look in the mirror and
see that